las aumentó de 15 a 18 años nos
referimos a Mohamed grayev y chogri
chafrut ellos son dos de los acusados
que comparecían por asociación ilícita
terrorista esto generó los aplausos de
la audiencia entre los que se cuentan
muchos familiares de víctimas o incluso
personas que estuvieron en ese atentado
del 14 de Julio a lo que el presidente
de la corte respondió pidiendo silencio
dijo evitemos las manifestaciones son
inadmisibles la justicia necesita de
serenidad en el caso del Tercer acusado
por asociación ilícita terrorista la
corte ha hecho caso de las sugerencias
del Ministerio Público le quitó esa
calificación y lo condenó finalmente a
doce años de cárcel el Ministerio
Público había pedido quince años en el
resto de los acusados que comparecían
todos por violaciones a la ley deporte
de armas y a la ley de venta y tráfico
de armas la corte mantuvo las penas
solicitadas por el Ministerio Público
van de cinco a dos años de cárcel y
de esta banda justamente de tráfico de
armas a hartan enar le redujo la pena
que había solicitado al Ministerio
Público de diez a ocho años